do you accept that there were serious
failings in that first investigation
into Nikki Allen's death
I would acknowledge that there were
mistakes in the original investigation
and those are well documented some of
those mistakes have led to changes in
National Police practice particularly
around police interviewing so yes I
acknowledge those mistakes but it's
important to recognize that northumbria
police have never given up on the search
for Nikki Allen's killer we've
constantly reviewed new lines of inquiry
new evidence available and that's what
led to us using new forensic science in
2017 that ultimately led to the
conviction of David Boyd last week I
think there was there was too much focus
on on one individual in George Herron
and I think it's well documented that
the the interviewing of George Herron
was completely inappropriate and led to
an innocent man being put on trial that
was wrong and and I've written a
personal letter of apology to George
Herron for the way in which that was
done and the impact that that's had on
his whole life I think it was really
important because when when you look at
what's happened clearly there's been an
enormous impact on George Heron's life
you know and that was wrong that was as
a result of the way in which northumbria
police treated Georgetown back in 1992
and I think
apology is very important his life was
irreparably changed and damaged he had
to move away from the area and he was
associated with one of the worst crimes
you can imagine
this that surely doesn't go
what doesn't fix that harm
I can never fix the impact on his life
of over 30 years but I think an apology
is really important it's a sincere
apology from nothing we're pleased that
says we're truly sorry for the weight
which he was treated and the impact it's
had on his life so I do think that an
apology is very important